let's talk about this guy named Joe
Biden okay let's talk about what he's
got going on
okay so uh Joe Biden proposes largest
tax increase in cell BJ political
Insider Biden's 2023 fiscal budget
reposes that all the bad ideas that
Congress won't pass and as a new twist
the coveted liberal wealth tax bidens
wishlist calls for increasing the top
marginal tax rate to 39.6 from 37 it
would also nearly double on capital
gains to 39.6 for people earning over a
million dollars this would be the
highest tax rate on investment gains
since 1920s this tax unrealized gains
which are not taxed until assets are
converted to income liquid since liquid
assets make up less than 20 percent of
the wealth investors will have to
incentivize to hold liquid assets such
as real estate to avoid liquidating
stocks to pay taxes rather than sell
stocks to diversify to reinvest
investors will be forced to sell stocks
to pay taxes on realized capital gains
do you think there is a chance that any
of this stuff's gonna pass through or do
you think a guy named Joe manchin is
going to say listen have I not already
made it clear I'm not supporting a
massive tax increase what do you think
is going to happen here I think you're
right I don't think anything's going to
really get passed uh it may be a baby
step maybe a part of that proposal gets
gets through the you know that everyone
can agree upon is a reasonable tax but
that at least we're talking about
politics now what we should be talking
about tax rates what is a fair tax rate
what is an unfair tax rate what is an
unfair loophole for the wealthy what is
you know a bad policy you always talk
about
Democrats having terrible fiscal policy
what are the good policies where do you
draw the line when you talk about taxes
being a a punishment or a reward for
being a member of the society where you
can become wealthy what is that line and
that's what the debate is and it shifts
depending on the economic state of the
country let me ask you so how hard do
you think it is to start a business and
make it succeed how hard do you think it
is I know how hard it is okay how hard
you think it is it's really hard so
unpack that like how hard is really hard
like what's a lifetime of commitment
does it affect your personal life in
every way do you miss some birthdays do
you miss practices do you miss dinners
do you miss how many people are willing
to go through that okay so now let's go
another side what else a job or
occupation is harder than being a
business owner that requires a lot of
risk and requires you having to do work
that you're not going to get paid
maybe any money for a while what's
harder job than that
professional athlete
I think professional that's just random
that's just but I think that's a game
though I think that's genetics a part of
it is genetics a part of it is I can't
jump 46 inches right so I think that is
the luck of the draw like Shannon Sharpe
says listen man I understand I was born
like this you there's nothing you can do
to be as athletic as I am right you've
seen Shannon sharp yeah guy's a monster
right what do you think's as hard
as that I struggle to answer that
question because I think every Endeavor
is a business in right unless you're an
artist but you're still trying to sell
your art you still gotta eat
yeah but but but the risk of starting a
business putting your all your money in
it
it is so challenging so Hollywood let's
go to Hollywood it is so hard to make it
in Hollywood how hard is it it's easier
to get struck by lightning twice in your
life than to be a successful working
okay so look what you just said right
okay really so yeah so let me ask let me
ask you a question you think uh Steph
Curry you know do we have a Stephen
Curry without a uh Dell Curry no no we
don't have a Stephen Curry with adelker
do we have a Peyton Manning or Eli
Manning without Archie Manning no sir do
we have a Tiger Woods without his father
no do we have a the Williams sisters
without the Father Richard no we don't
have it right okay so that's luck of the
draw right who your father is there's a
lot of incent and benefits that you have
with that but
some of these guys that work their asses
off to get there man if a guy gets paid
a lot of money and he had to do a lot of
sacrifice and work to get there I
support that cause for him to make that
money you have to create incentive for
whatever is very very hard or else
people are just not going to do it
that's the basic premise for me with
taxes right I get that whatever's very
hard I want to create that incentive
bigger for you so now as a government
when it comes out to taxes so you're
you're a parent you have kids you're uh
a parent you have two kittens I'm a
parent I have four kids right as a
parent who has kids you know you as a as
a parent sit there and say that guy took
that pressure off my plate wow pretty
impressive so if you like this clip and
you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
[Music]